limited volume vials there's three kinds
Max recovery insert vials and
polypropylene insert vials or plastic
limited volume vials are imperative to
use when you have a limited amount of
sample a limited volume vial raises the
height of the sample in the vial so your
auto sampler can pick up the sample more
easily the two most important
specifications to focus on are residual
volume which is how much volume is lost
in the vial and total volume which is
how much sample volume can be put in the
vial next Max recovery vials are
designed with a conical bottom for the
best sample recovery these allow for
high sample volume and low residual
volume it also minimizes
cross-contamination by eliminating the
need to transfer the sample to micro
volume inserts limited volume vials have
low residual volume but hold low sample
volume polypropylene vials are similar
to limited vials but they are plastic
for applications that need them they are
also very cost effective when you see a
descriptor like 9 to 425 the first
number is the diameter nine millimeters
and the second number is the thread size
425. choose amber glass if your analyte
is light sensitive and clear glass if
it's not